bon imaginons demain je vous confie le
poste quelle décision prenez-vous
d'emblée alors oui 1er mai pardon oui à
l'iss le stagiaire il reste une heure
avec toi et après ce que tu peux
l'envoyer en compte
oui mais c'est pourquoi j'ai dit oui oui
j'ai pas que ça à [ __ ] très bien merci
beaucoup à l'iss génial oui comment tu
t'appelles déjà rien donc apte à bien
cet acte soit ici n'a pas peur alors
damien je te présente c'est martin a
lors d'un entretien et il regarde si si
son profil correspond aux attentes de
l'entreprise les milieux chômage
enfin peut-être je sais pas d'ailleurs
mais tu peux lui demander ça vous
dérange pas on l'appliqué on l'appliqué
tient avec mais bon va même tenter un
truc c'est toi damien qui va poser les
questions
voilà une bonne idée ça c'est de la rh
2.0
allez allez vas-y je vous confie le
poste quelle décision prenez-vous
d'emblée dans l'union dans cet anglais
alors je vous confie le poste quelle
décision qu'au niveau d'anglais chlore
pour moi la sauce c'est bien d'affirmer
faut que tu regarde vraiment bien dans
les yeux alors pour moi les décisions
prenez-vous d'emblée très bien pour moi
la chose me regarde je suis invisible
annoncé cesser à damien qu'il faut
répondre
alors pour moi en tout cas j'ai une idée
bien tu vas mettre en face voilà pas de
mettre votre maître en face à côté lui
comme ça moi je vois comment vous vous
débrouillez tous les deux chez observe
la ceinture agir ces master class à jour
pas je vous en prie alors tu vois
lorsque vous voyez quand même bon
d'entretien moi j'ai vu oui oui il est
bien
alors vous voyez
pardon mais ça m'a pas du tout là ok ok
je comprends très bien
un entretien c'est une situation
stressante d'accord à ce que tu dois
faire c'est chercher la connivence
tu peux tu peux le relancer en lui
disant quelque chose de gentil qui allez
vas-y champions league ce que tu as dans
le monde
c'est nouveau ça c'est de la rage 3.0 et
4.0 faut se réinventer c'est super vous
avez une belle cravate ou et parme il
rend nuit je les adore merci et tout ça
tu peux une question simple salle quels
sont vos plus gros défaut via direct
simple efficace et écoutez je dirais que
j'ai parfois tendance à trop investir
ses parts des fonds semble non c'est pas
un défaut damien c'est quoi pour toi en
défaut par exemple viola menteur menteur
par exemple très bien voilà mentor sauf
qu'on entretient on dit pas ce genre de
défaut tiens tu sais ce qu'on va faire
damien et tu m'a posé tour une question
qu'est ce que tu veux savoir la relève
est assurée regarde le est magnifique ce
qu'est ce que tu veux savoir
vous voulez combien de fois où ça vient
d'un petit peu tôt dans l'entretien et
en même temps et en même temps l'argent
c'est important c'est important l'argent
alors on entretient on dirait plutôt
quels sont vos prétentions salariales
ainsi quels sont vos prétentions
salariales sur mon poste actuel je suis
à 35 gagne 20 ko qu'elle passe la
seconde
pour être franc je suis un moment de
macquarie saka surtout répond pas là
pour parer comparer comparer pompe à 30
femme appelée madame mcaleese oui la lys
à plus tard toi tu vas faire craquer
toutes les filles merci m
[Musique]
dacquois way petit con